what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today it's another
week another spider war video today this
came out a few days ago actually
spider-man no way home second trailer
toby and andrew debut release date
update yeah i was out of town so i was
like i'll check this out when we come
back and now here we are to check this
out now that i'm back now let's do this
now that i'm back because toby and
andrew are coming back
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man no way home the first
teaser trailer that we got for
spider-man no way home broke the record
for most viewed trailer in a 24 hour
period beating avengers end game to do
that which is quite impressive but now
it has some competition and that
competition is its official second
trailer which would be a full trailer
they surprisingly gave us a lot in the
teaser trailer i actually didn't think
they were gonna show any of the
multiversal sinister six at all let
alone show doc ock right up in front yet
they did and it makes you wonder what
exactly are they going to show in the
full trailer the official full-length
trailer that is supposed to give us the
entire plot of the movie you just have
to think if this was the teaser what is
the full thing and how do you go bigger
and make people even more excited about
the film well according to some reports
it looks like marvel and sony might have
figured that out and we have some news
on when to possibly expect that second
trailer to get here as well along with
how long the actual movie could actually
be according to the tournament
source the spider-man no way home film
is going to be two hours and 37 minutes
long now i want to address this because
this is in no way a confirmation that
the movie is indeed going to be that
long after all right now the film is
still being put together the official
run time might not be set yet and they
didn't report a source for this report
which is understandable in some cases
sometimes i get told information that i
tell to the public but i can't exactly
tell who my source is because they could
get in trouble but as of right now i'm
going to take this as a rumor especially
since when films get completed their run
time can change but if this is somewhat
true or near what we could expect from
the movie's runtime it's going to be a
pretty long movie i mean i wouldn't
expect it to be any less than two and a
half hours if you're going to be
introducing all these villains or
reintroducing these characters the plot
that we know so far in order for this to
feel like there's breathing room to not
feel rushed it's so easy for these
spider-man movies to feel jam-packed and
over-convoluted and they often have to
suffer due to their lack of run time
which is a concern that i already have
would this movie as exciting and cool as
it looks i think two and a half hours is
reasonable enough time to get it all
done two hours 37 minutes it's actually
even better in my opinion so i would i
wouldn't object against a three hour run
time for this film i don't feel like
it's likely but i wouldn't object
against it not at all i actually think
the movie does need quite a bit of time
especially if you're going to involve so
many different characters and they're
going to come from different universes
especially if you consider that the
majority of the people that are gonna go
watch it aren't exactly like us they're
not on the internet every day looking up
videos looking up leaks there's a lot of
people that are going to go into this
movie blind simply because they love
spider-man so for those people who
haven't done that much research like us
they're probably going to need some
explaining when it comes to the
multiverse and when it comes to variants
so i personally think that a two and a
half hour run time would be great for
everybody because i could seriously sit
down and watch like a four hour movie
but now let's talk about that second
spider-man no way home trailer and this
trailer from what i'm hearing and the
rumors going around out there this
trailer sounds like it could break the
previous trailer's record specifically
because of what it could possibly show
to the world and that of course is the
three spider-man and the whole entire
sinister six and what's interesting is
we still don't actually know that sixth
villain is it kind of makes me think
that it could be ned as hobgoblin but
more on that in a bit now we have a few
people reporting that the second trailer
for spider-man no way home is indeed
going to give us a shot of the three
spider-man
the first report that is coming from big
screen leaks who is a verified account
on twitter who have dropped accurate
information about spider-man no way home
in the past they tweeted the other day
so right now i hear that the plan is for
totes
when we get that shot
the money shot but even without seeing
the other spider-man this trailer broke
the record for most viewed trailer in 24
hours so if the money shot of the next
trailer is going to be the three
spider-man together that could
definitely break the record i don't know
how view counts work on some other
platforms but i imagine
that with second viewing there'll
probably be more re-watchability for
this trailer everyone who watched the
first trailer is probably going to watch
the second trailer right so i'd imagine
it would rewatch ability and probably
even get more views you know oh yeah
clip that much more so totally bet that
if you showed that i've been there of
course it's gonna pass the first one
undoubtably and my other theory is that
i wonder if we're gonna see kingpin in
this like there's already rumors
circulating he's supposed to reprise his
role vincent d'onofrio in a disney plus
show and usually the sinister six often
has kingpin and not as one of the six
but usually sometimes calling the shots
or something along the lines of that
nature and you know if daredevil really
is in this it would also make sense to
bring kingpin back in it and kingpin is
one of spider-man's foes so plus what a
way to get a late in the game surprise
yeah we're already not expecting like
you know we were expecting so many
things i feel like that would actually
be kind of surprising now of course
they're not going to show them the
entire time they're probably going to
spend a lot of time talking about the
villains and the multiverse in the
official trailer we need more about the
actual plot of the movie and the actual
main plot of the movie is that the
multiverse is kind of breaking or
bursting into madness if you will and
villains from other spider-man universes
are starting to come into tom holland's
universe this will have to be explained
in the trailer to the public they're
going to have to really tell them what's
going on true funny story like a day
after the spider-man no way home trailer
came out i had a buddy call me and he's
like 55 years old and he says hey i just
watched the new spider-man trailer can
you kind of explain it to me because it
looks like they're running out of ideas
and i'm like what then i explained it to
him i explained the spider verse and all
three spiderman showing up together and
he was like yeah are they just running
out of ideas that they just got to put
them all together now and my mind was
kind of blown by that statement but he's
the perfect example of somebody who is
going to need some explaining on what is
happening and it sounds like that's kind
of what's going to be happening in the
trailer thankfully 55 year olds are not
the target demographic warrants i miss
the part where that's my frog
catch up watch the
movies pizza time more like nap time for
your 55 year old friend get some fresh
ideas when you fix this damn door
applesauce time and according to another
update account spider.fan1962
the main trailer is going to focus on
the sinister six it's going to show us
more about the multiverse and apparently
it's actually going to show charlie cox
in the trailer
wow
which technically we have already gotten
and like i mentioned before the fact
that spider-man's identity is going to
be erased and nobody is going to know
that peter parker is indeed spider-man
makes me believe that ned isn't going to
know he's spider-man and if they're
pegging spider-man to be a killer
perhaps ned won't actually like
spider-man in this film he'll like his
buddy peter but not spider-man and
perhaps he becomes hobgoblin somehow now
i myself admit that this is a pretty
out-there theory and all it would
probably take for this to not happen is
for peter to simply say hey i'm
spider-man we went through a lot
together but doctor strange erased her
memory but it's curious that marvel is
kind of keeping the secret so well under
wraps of who this sixth villain is we've
heard like zero leaks about this at all
and let's be honest this movie isn't
exactly known for keeping it secret so
it must be somebody pretty special i
really don't want them to do that hop
gobbling in this movie i mean if
anything he could spider-man to every
up that he could be hop goblin in the
next movie but guys do you remember
amazing spider-man too when they [ __ ]
forced damn uh harry osborne to become
goblin in that movie it was like oh god
why is it too much i thought the movie
was almost over it really is
that movie don't attack it on this in
the movie where you meet him yeah don't
tack it on in this man it'll be galactus
just watch
but back to this report that is coming
from spider dot fan 1962. one final
thing they say is that the trailer is
going to come after the 22nd of october
not before that and this date actually
kind of lines up with what the studio
would want to do it's a couple of months
after the release of the first teaser
trailer and it's a couple of months
before the movie comes out the timing
for that pretty much lines up that's
typical timing of when they release
their trailers because you have to also
keep in mind that they're probably going
to show like a thousand tv spots between
the official trailer and the actual
release of the movie seriously during
spider-man fire from home they released
a new tv spot like every day and they're
doing that right now for shang qi so i'm
definitely expecting that so hopefully
we should be getting the trailer in
about a month and a half and from what
it sounds like the possibility of seeing
the other two spider-man appear in the
trailer is actually looking pretty good
i personally heard before that they're
not going to show them in the promotions
until the latter half of the marketing
but i guess this official trailer could
be considered the latter half of the
marketing they didn't show them in the
first they could show them in a second
now we'll have to wait and see but if
you want to stay up to date on all of
these updates be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell be sure to
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching we'll follow you with the whip
buddy whipped whip thank you so much
warren for putting that together you are
the spiderman channel
officially you are marvel's officials
sanctioned news and leaks for spider-man
racial spider-man channel now my mind
spider-chan thank you so much for being
here make sure to subscribe check out
warren's channel cause we wonder if you
haven't done so already on his way to
surpass us in subscriber count
undoubtedly last but not least
lance door when it inevitably happens
that they turn ned into hobgoblin i
think they're gonna need a bit of a
buffer looking guy to do some of the
action scenes and that's where you come
in my dude you got all those charms so
you could play those notes of the
character like oh man but there's still
ned in there he's such a nice kind
lovable guy you know your big jacked
fireman's bod that you know can make
somebody feel so safe in one instance
and then so terrified and intimidated in
another instance i feel like you would
be the perfect casting choice plus then
from there you can start your taylor
lautner career you know just like put
your abs on the covers of various
straight to dvd movies you'll do after
this you know work out your charm on the
small screen maybe make friends with
adam sandler and be in a couple of his
movies perfect hollywood trajectory
lance dorr hell yeah thanks for all your
love and support and uh we'll catch you
the next time that there's a spider-man
video which is gonna be really soon so
so be ready for that
oh no